محمد رمضان نشر صور على حساباته وهو راجع
من امريكا بطياره خاصه وجنبه على الكرسي
رزم من الدولارات الصوره اشعلت جدل كبير
جدا وانتقادات مو اول مره يواجهها محمد
رمضان حقيقه وهي انتقادات التباهي بالفلوس
وما حد عارف لو الانتقادات هي سبب او ايش
لكن محمد رمضان رجع وحذف الصور وخلى بس
صوره وحده واضحه فيها الدولارات من زاويه
ضيقه جدا الناس انتقدت الاستعراض وخصوصا
انه في كثير ناس ظروفه صعبه ومصر فيها
ازمه دولار هذا غير تبعات التعويم ومن بين
الناس كمان اللي هاجموا رمضان كانت دكتور
جمال شعبان طبيب بامراض القلب اللي رد على
صور محمد رمضان قال له في انه يا ريت
بالدولارات اللي معاك تشتري منظمات
كهربائي منظمات كهربائيه للغلابه اللي في
العنايه المركزه وعندهم احتمال السكته
والتوقف القلبي المفاجئ مجرد على بوست
الدكتور من محمد رمضان اللي طلب منه اسماء
المستشفيات اللي بحاجه للاجهزه وطلب كمان
رقم تليفون
الدكتور وقال الدكتور انه تكلم مع رمضان
واتفقوا انه يزور احدى القرى الفقيره معه
ويساعد الناس اللي محتاجين فيها وانه رح
يتم تحديد حالات طارئه عشان يساعدوهم وقال
كمان انه اقترح على محمد رمضان تاسيس
جمعيه خيريه وانه رحب بالفكره كمان
والموضوع ما توقف هنا لا جدل الصور وصل
لمكان رسمي تحديدا نحن بنتكلم عن قبه
البرلمان صار في تحرك برلماني ضد رمضان
فاحدى النائبات وجهت مذكره لرئيس المجلس
طالبت فيها وزير الماليه ورئيس مصلحه
الضرائب في مصر بتوضيح اذا كان محمد رمضان
بيدفع الضرائب اللي مترتبه عليه وقالت ان
محمد رمضان اللي بيسمي نفسه نمبر وان هو
اعلى الفنانين اجرا في مصر وانه ولا مره
طول مشواره الفني قدم اسهامات او مشاركات
مجتمعيه مثل غيرهم من الفنانين وقالت كمان
انه واجه في يونيو 2020 اتهام بالتهرب
الضريبي لانه قدم اقرارات ضريبي او قدم
اقرار تحديد ضريبي بيانات مو صحيحه عن
ارباح ومكاسبه واخفى ارقام دخلوا الرسميه
والصحيحه
طيب للتذكير المشاهدين هذه المره الاولى
لمحمد رمضان بيثير الجدل بصوره اللي
بيعتبرها كثير من الناس استعراض للفلوسه
فمن قبل طلع في فيديو هو بيرمي الدولارات
في مسبح وكانت قصه كبيره وهذا غير الصور
اللي بين فتره وفتره بينزلها والناس
بتعتبرها استعراض لاسطول سياراته الفارهه
في مره ثانيه كمان صارت ازمه وجدل برضه
بسبب فيديو عرض في فرشه اسنان ومعجون
اسنان من الذهب